You were once a kicking, screaming, tiny little
human.
I know, it’s hard to believe, right?
Since you probably can’t remember a single
thing about being a baby.
Most of your early childhood is probably a
memory-less void, and the few events you do
remember are likely hazy.
This phenomenon is known as “childhood amnesia”
and it happens to everyone.
Some people are better at remembering than
others but we’re all pretty bad at it.
But why is it so hard to remember life as
a baby?
Let’s find out.
It’s believed that memories start to form
in our brain as soon as we’re born and maybe
even before, however, studies have found that
children don’t actually store those memories
permanently, so that they can later be accessed
in adult life.
We don’t start storing memories in a somewhat
semi-permanent manner until the ages of four
to seven.
We can usually remember certain important
events that occurred between the ages of four
and seven.
But before the age of four, nothing.
In fact, during a study, children between
the ages of four and seven were told things
that they definitely did and said two years
prior, but none of the children could remember
doing or saying them.
Most of the children actually said “that
wasn’t me, it was someone else”.
Infamous neurologist and pioneering phycologist
Sigmund Freud believed that we repress our
earliest childhood memories because this period
of time is so full of psychosexual content
that we simply wouldn’t be able to handle
such disturbing memories, even as an adult.
But nowadays that theory carries very little
gravitas.
More recently however new theories have emerged
that attempt to once and for all explain this
mysterious childhood memory loss.
The first of these is that as an infant our
brain quite simply isn’t sufficiently developed
yet.
The two parts of our brain necessary for forming
new memories, the hippocampus and the medial
temporal lobe are already well developed by
the time we’re one-year-old.
However, another part of our brain called
the prefrontal cortex doesn’t fully develop
until our early twenties.
It is believed the prefrontal cortex is responsible
for creating episodic memories.
Which are memories of actual events.
Being able to remember what happened, where
it happened and roughly at what time it happened
is a skill our brains don’t master until
later on in life.
Until this time our brain is only able to
remember skills we’ve learnt as well as
cosmetic things such as items and faces.
As babies we aren’t able to attach emotions
to these things, so they don’t transform
into events and are therefore less memorable.
Another theory that compounds this effect
is that as babies we aren’t able to talk.
We have no language.
That’s quite significant, because it means
we were never able to represent memories with
words.
For example, if you think back to the day
when you moved into a new house your can probably
remember distinguishable aspects of that day,
such as, the house had six windows and a blue
door and you arrived at your new house in
a small red car.
If an infant were to be placed in the exact
same situation it wouldn’t be able to attach
words to the event because a baby has no idea
what a window or a door is, never mind how
to describe them.
So the infant wouldn’t be able to make that
all-important link between words and memories,
which is what we do all the time as adults.
Psychologists think that by attaching language
to memories in this way, it helps our brain
to organise and store them more efficiently.
So, if we’re able to describe a thing or
an event with words it’s considerably more
likely that our brain will remember it several
years down the line.
By the time the average child reaches four
years old it knows about 5,000 words.
That’s just enough to be able to describe
most things and events.
Even if those descriptions are rather basic,
it doesn’t matter, it’s still fuel being
added to the memory tank.
This process of attaching words to memories
is further reinforced by the fact that when
we learn a language, we’re then able to
talk about things we’ve seen, with others.
And every time we talk about something that’s
happened, we’re much more likely to remember
it in the future.
That’s why your granddad has told you that
exact same story about when he was a young
lad a hundred bloody times and continues to
do so every time you see him.
Because he’s told it so many times, that
it’s nigh on impossible for his brain to
forget it.
These theories do have some weight to them
and they’re widely regarded as some as the
best theories we currently have to explain
why we can’t remember life as a toddler.
But there’s brand new evidence that may
once and for all, definitively explain this
phenomenon.
We all know just how much scientists love
to answer questions by experimenting on rats
and this question is no exception.
In an experiment scientists controlled the
speed at which rat’s brains were able to
make new brain cells.
They found that when they slowed down the
rat’s ability to generate new brain cells
the rats were able to form more solid, clearer
memories and they were able to recall memories
easier.
Conversely, when they sped-up the rat’s
ability to make new brain cells the rats were
more forgetful and their memories became fuzzier.
Now before you ask, how they were able to
test the rat’s memories?
Let me explain, I mean they couldn’t exactly
interview them, could they?
The scientists did this by associating a place
with a mild electric shock, then observing
how the rats reacted when they returned to
that same place in the future.
But shouldn’t it be the other way around?
Shouldn’t the rats who had their brain cell
production rate increased, have been able
to remember more, not less?
You would think so, but here’s why it’s
actually the opposite way around.
Just like a computer hard drive, our brains
have limited storage space.
There’s only room for so many brain cells,
so our ability to store memories is limited.
This means that when new brain cells are created,
if there’s no more space remaining, then
they have to overwrite old ones.
So when a new memory is created, if there
isn’t any spare room our brain decides which
memories are useless and can therefore be
forgotten and deletes them to make room for
the new memory.
Oh and before you say we’re born with so
many brain cells and we can’t grow new ones,
that rumour simply isn’t true.
Research has shown that brain cells and neurons
continue to grow in our brains throughout
our entire lives, although the process does
slow down somewhat as we age.
So why does this deletion of memories occur
more often as an infant than as an adult?
Two reasons, the first is that our brains
are developing at an astonishingly fast rate
as a child.
We are learning and developing faster than
we ever will in the remainder of our life.
So a lot of room needs to be made for new
memories and skills we learn.
Secondly, a lot of what we experience as an
infant is deemed non-essential by our brain.
Because let’s face it, you don’t need
to remember the time you were on all fours
in your garden and tried to eat a tulip.
So all these useless memories we create as
an infant are the first to be discarded when
new memories are created and new skills are
learnt as we grow up.
So to summarise, we can’t remember being
a baby because our brains have emptied the
trash, because our hard drive was getting
rather full.